では来分から始まり
ますでは皆さがして
ください
[音楽]
さと
UD
[音楽]
ung
amp
[音楽]
ampUD
amp
[音楽]
AMA
amp
ung
[音楽]
amp
U
.
amp
[音楽]
ung
U
[音楽]
AMA
U
[音楽]
AMA
では慈悲の名所いたし
ます私は
幸せでありますよう
に私の
悩み
苦しみ
が
なくなりますように
[音楽]
[拍手]
り
せでなりまよ
に私はしはせでなりまよ
に
わたし
はしでりまよに
私はバでりますようにと念じ
ます
[音楽]
[拍手]
EM
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますよ
に
わたしのした
しめの
ネ
とが
り
よ
[音楽]
What
EM
シせでなりますよう
にしし生命が幸せなりますように繰り返し
なり
ます
生きとし
いけるものが
幸せでなりますよう
に生きと
しけるものの
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますよう
に生きと
しけるものの
[音楽]
マ
り
[音楽]
の生きと
しけるものが
ししでなりますよう
に生きと
しけるものが
やせがりますよ
に
けるものが
アでありますよう
に生きとしけるものが幸せでありますよう
にと繰り返しなげ
ます
[音楽]
IKせてありますよ
にきと
しかるものがシはしでなります
よう
にはいありがとうござい
ますではよろしくお願いします
えっと
あ過の最後の方案会になりますそろそろ
新しいえ年にもなります今日のあの法制の
あの海上費のお伏をなさった方々の名前を
今表示してると思いますねまあ子さんと
うん
住え新立さんそれから
滝沢孫さんえ前田まり子様ていう
えりの方々りのなさった方々
に3ぼのごがありましておえなりますよう
に心がらになりますようにすることがいけ
ましょうにと成願いたします
ササで今日のテーマはあのすごいあの
シンプルでえ簡単で
え進めたいと思いますあの人生設計数の
書き
方自分の人生は自分で決めるっていうこと
でであの私はこのこのように書きましょと
いう風に具体的には言えません
まあなぜならそれ自分で決めればいいって
いうこと
で
で我々はすごいあの殺
な世界できてる
しこの
社会が動くためにいろんなことを行わなく
ちゃいけないんです
ねだから小さな小さなことたくさん集まっ
てそれで起動して社会っていうもの
成り立ってます
[音楽]
ねですから人々は
自分の好みのパートをやってるんですね
ほんのちょっとのことしかやってないん
です
ね例えばこのビルネス立っても
えま生じするシがありますし管理する
ところがありますし電気のセクションが
ありますしね水道ガスなどなどのたくさん
小ちゃな小ちゃなパートがありまして
ねまそれで見るてこと成り立ってい
て
で今我々はそのフルすうというパートやっ
てるんですねフルスカそらに座ってスカけ
であるんだけど部がってみにて
コントローラけではないんですね
えまそういう風なことでま人生がこの
小さな小さなパートで成り立ってるんです
ねだから誰がが偉いってことがないん
ですま政府のしたってもまいる地方議員が
いて国会議員がいてその中で何人か選んで
えっと大臣という風に
え隠れを通すと選んでるしその中のえボス
が必勝でしょうしえ自分に与えられたパト
やってるだけでね
えまそれで世界が慣れたってるんですねだ
から誰の仕事も生き方も決して警視する
ことは不可能
ですそれ解していただければ
ね人間なんが自分の仕事をなんか
うんま警視するという
ねすごい
悪い性格ある方々いるんですね逆もダメな
自分が偉い仕事してるんだ
とこれ両方も大きな問題なんですよ
で会社だったら社長がいるんだけど社長が
偉いわけじゃないん
です社員の立場が低いわけじゃないんです
両方い
て会社が成り立ってるん
ですだから誰のパートも大事なん
でしょ我々飛行機に乗ったら我々は
ティケット買ってお金払って座るで
まあコミューターまパッセンジャー
の役をやっていてそれで我々には動く範囲
は決まってるんです
ねで機内のスタフがいてスタフは自分の
仕事やっていて
で告別の中で3人ぐらいいてそちらそちら
の仕事やってい
て誰が偉いんですか
ね人は乗らなかっ
たらあの飛を飛ばす一そらない
でしょうですから消する方々は
すごく丁寧
に安全
にを飛ばして着しようという仕をやってい
てそはそれからそこに出ていくんです我々
には顔を見ることできない
分からだから誰ががやという世界がな
でしょたで活かするですねま出通ってで
仕事をするそればあまり大したことないで
えるすごい大事な仕方
をだからどんな仕事でたってもそを社しし
てれる一部であるなら
ばも平等で検討でもう隠せない仕事でだ
からこれるのは自分の仕事を偉いと思う
こととえあれは
あまり立場がない仕事をしてるんだていう
この2つは入る
[音楽]
とかなりえトラブルが起ます
ね
だから仏教の立場から人はこんな指で選ぶ
べきっていうことはないん
ですしかし人間
だ先生すいませ
んバイクの優先にたい優先のマイクに書い
たいのでちょっとえてもらっていいです
かマイクどうなってるのマちょっと先の
マイクにうん変更したいのでうんはい
ちょっとお待ちいただき
ます
すいませんえっとマイクトラブルでえ
ちょっと中断させていただき
ます大丈夫ですかもうちょっと待ち
ください
うん
あ
えっと書いて
ますそれであの人生の設計すっていうのは
まあ1人1人が自分の人生をプ
面すればよろしいていうことですね
えそれにあの仏教の考えはどうなってるの
かとこれから考えていきましょうまずは
あのトラベルのところ説明していき
ます
でちょっとおかしいフレスいっぱい使い
ましたけどあの運命の遺伝子というだから
これは運命の遺伝子ではなくてこの慌てて
夜かきましたから運命という遺伝子なん
です遺伝子がっていうことではなくてね
なんかかまあ遺伝子っていうのはどう
しようもないという意味でもありますから
あのこれは精神なことでけな我々運命と
いうものを考えてるんですねで人は運命を
信じるんです
ねだから自分の仕事をして空で落ち着いて
生きていられなくなっちゃうね運命って
いう気持ちが入っちゃう
と
なんか偉いとぶちゃうんです
よこれって私の運命ですかとかねずっと
こんなことばっかしやってどうでしょうか
とか
ねそうすると自分のことを
[音楽]
なんか
え悪く評価し
たりあるいは高く評価したりするトラブル
が起きちゃうんです
ねそこでなんで人間が運命って
いう言葉使ってるのか
とで言葉使ってるとこそういう働きが心理
的にあるん
です生けてる上
で運命と
いう遺伝子が働いてるんです
この結果になったのは命の
流れ客観的にしっかりと誰もりしてないん
ですただ生けてるだけ
でで川で川にて流されてるんですよそ流さ
れてる姿を外から空からしっかり見
るっていうことはね見てないんでしょうね
これはまできないし
ね川の流れを全体的に見て
えここら辺はとても危険ここら辺はそれ
ほど危険じゃないえー流れることから身を
救うならばこの場所でやった方がいいとか
そんなこと分かってないまただ流されてる
だけそうじゃあ自分が代わり流されてると
思って
くださいそうすると運命です
ねなんか激しい流れに入っちゃうと最悪
もうどうしようもなくてで
すごい怪我したりえ死んだり可能性もあり
ます緩やかな流れに入っちゃうとちょっと
落ち着い
て周りを見て逃げられるのかっぱり幅が
広くて逃げられないじゃあまたいるともし
かするとあここ
で握られますという風
に
だからそこ
もできなくてパスになっちゃうとやっぱり
運命ですねとか川に流されて死ぬ運命です
ねっていう風に思ってしまうんですねだ
から人生が流れてる命が流れて人生では
なくて流れてるんですねそれは外から客観
的に見てないんだから運命という概念が
現れてくるん
です
と言っても我々にはそれちょっと無理です
ねだからできれ
ば外から命を感謝することがあっ
たらやってみ
たら運命というこの悪い遺伝子が聞ちゃう
んですえ客観的
な
けで我はただ命にてる
です失敗するたびに運命の性にします成功
すると生き方が暴走しますその人々の場合
は失敗するとやってることがねま運命だ
からねま私の運命だからしょうがないやと
かね運命のてせちゃうしうまくいくと調子
に乗っちゃって人生暴走させ
ちゃうちも結ない
ですりは人間それでどんなことになるかと
いうとこのあ日本語の単語を見つかりませ
んで言ったけどセルフコントロール自分を
コントロールすることセルフ
マネジメント自分自身のマネジメンができ
なくなるんですねだから仏教的ないうのは
セルフ
コントロール自分
を管理せてください
と自分自身で自分のために自分を
マネジメンしてください
といいマネージャーになってくださいと誰
の自分
のでこれがこの運命で
を取り外すために必なもの
でえだからこれあまりダメになるんです
これ人類の問題とてこれあんまり宗教は
関係ないんでどんな人間
も動物はと思ってるかどうか思ってない
でしょうねこれホモサピエの問題なんです
ねどうしても運命という考えが言てるん
です
ね
はいそれから我々
の心にこのスレーブエマスタモデュールと
いうまた遺伝子みたいなモジュールが入っ
てるんですね奴隷と主人と
いう誰も俺気づかないんですよ
我々の心の中でどれがいて主人もいるんだ
よ
とこれもいらんものなん
ですいらんものですがいるんですね
入り込んじゃってこのビラス
がこれ鳥のさなかないこれで生きることが
はちゃめちゃなことになるんですね
よくあること我々は言われる通りにやり
たいん
です一でもどうすればいいと他人で聞くん
ですみんなにマニュアル償です
ねで会社で仕事をする時のマニュアルあっ
て悪くないあの飛行機の場は少は一緒で
メニルがそこでもう固定して設定してある
ん
ですそれページめくりながらやってるん
ですまそれはそれで別に問題ないんだけど
ね先体的に自分自身のジンにマだがかん
でか
学校に行ったら学生としての生き方教師と
しての生き方とかまそれぞれ決まりあって
構いませんよこれちっちゃな線だから
ね命の全体ではないんだから
ね例えば警察官はあの交通ルー破っちゃう
人々調べるとマニなるん
でしょこういうことこういうことこういう
ことは違反であると違反し体と見つけたら
どうやって喋るのかどう対応するのか
どんなていうんで
これ会計するのかってことでメニなるん
ですでもそれはその警察感が父とし
て子供と対対応する時はアウト使えません
よだからすっごい面倒ややこしいんでしょ
我々はどうしてもマニュアルがくださいと
言ってるん
ですそれが自分で生きるためにも誰かさん
がメニルください
と私はどの通りにどるにやりまっとこれは
スレモデュールなん
です奴隷電子なん
です自分の人生に関して何でも他人の司令
に合わせますね同時に他人を支配したいと
いう気持ちもありますまどれだけだったら
分かりやすいねシンプルでこれ
にもう
主人と
いうビルスも入ってるんです
ねこの人何とすもろなこと知らないくせに
死支配しようとするん
ですあんたがすいませこしなせこれはダメ
ではないかどうかギャギャギャギャ言っ
てるでしょ言ってる人分かってるわけじゃ
ないんですあ病気ですあの人の
あの主人モジュール
が恩になってるだけ
ですでそれは社会で必死な場合でま学校
だったら教師たちやらその管理するスタフ
がいてえ子供たちを管理しなくちゃいけ
ないこうしなさいこうしてはいけない
とこれ主人モデュールでやっちゃうと全部
おかしくなるん
ですだから主人として仕事をしなくちゃ
いけないってことありますね例えば警察が
我々は法律守ってるか法律犯してるのかと
調べるんだけど警察官が我々の主人じゃ
ないん
ですだからオシステムあるんだから主人の
役目やろうと思わないんですねやっちゃう
と警察官が法律主犯でえ逮捕され
ます
だから裁判かどういうところから何か指令
がないと固く操作はできませ
んだから我々の友達から知ってる人だっ
たらドア開けてドキンと入るんだ
けど警察は玄関で待ってるん
です入ってくださいというまでまますん
です
でも法律的にそちら我々調べるんだから上
ですけど
ねでもそういう社会でこの我々を管理する
人々が管理するのオですしかし主人モデル
使っちゃうと主人モデュール使っちゃうと
そこでおかしくなるん
ですだからお母さんが子供たちにしなさい
こしなさいこしなさいというのはいいんだ
けど母親がボスでも主人でもないんですだ
からボス役主人役やったところで必ず失敗
するんですなぜならばこの奴隷モジュール
主人モジュールていうの
はビレ
ですそれ理解しておいて
ごせ
そうで問題はこの相反
するモデュール2つなん
ですお互い心の中で住んでるんです
ねそこでこの主人モジュールと奴隷
モジュール隣り合わせになっちゃうと心の
中でも葛藤が生まれちゃってもおかしく
なっちゃって生きられなくなるん
ですしっかりともう壁で別れてるならば
オケですけどね自分の心の中でいる奴隷と
主人をねお互い会えないのにいかなる場合
でも
面会できないようにしておけばいいんだ
けど
でも時々一緒になっちゃうんですねなった
ところで人の人生どうなるかと分からない
んです
ね大体精神的に病気になりますその場合
は大体というかほとんどの場合は
ねよく見てくださいあの精神的に色々病気
があって普通社会人ではられ
ないあま仕事もできませんしえもうかなり
助けてもらう立場でいるんですよ助けて
もらう立場でいるその方々は偉い態度
でかいん
でしょでお世話する人々に司令するん
です例えばその人に自分で料理作る能力
ないとしましょう精神的な不安で不安定で
それで料理作ってくれたとにありがとうと
えはないんでこれあれがますいこれが
ますいも起き方が
まい言っちゃいますねだから一般的にこの
人はどうせ頭がおかしいとみんな批的に
言うんだけどだからあれって
あのドレモデュールと主人モデュールが
一緒になってるからなん
です我々にもどれ2つあっても全く合わせ
ないようにしてくて
くださいだってこの会の場合はシベルの私
です
ねでじりなっちゃって喋り出しちゃうと
こちら大騒ぎする喧嘩状態になるだけで
管理人に追い出される結果になるんです出
ていってください
としかし私はここで公園時間になるまで
主人役やるんであっ
て
それはオフ
でしょう出ない
と人生成り立たない
ですでここで私の話聞いちゃうんだけど
あのロビーであったら皆様も私はみんな
平等でどう元気ですかとかねどこから来た
のかとかね今日ご飯食べたのかとかね普通
の世界にならないといけないん
ですそういうわけで我々は自分の人生設計
しようと思うとこのモデル2つ
が結構とらぶるんですよだからそれ理解し
ましょうこの2つはいらないん
です我々は誰かの奴隷じゃないん
です社会の奴隷じゃないん
です逆に主人でもないん
ですだから両方持ってバランスとってて
混乱し
ましょ主人であるながらどれでいるとかね
かなり混乱して精神的におかしくなるん
ですだから仏教のおさ様の立場から言える
のはこの2つ
を取り除いて
くださいノマなて
くださだから人生設計する方々は書く方々
はこのその問題も考えた方がいいんですね
はい次に行き
ますえすはこれはあのままこの英語の単語
は借りたんですあのそれそのシステム全て
語れてるウシGというねえま日本語で言え
ば
信仰遺伝子なんです
ねあのの奴隷遺伝子の場合は主人がいるん
です似てるんですよ信仰遺伝子が働い
ちゃう
と主人誰ですか
ねはっきりしてないね世の中みんな進行
する対象作ってるん
です日本伝的なやせの神毛もいるんだよと
稼いてくれわても名前知ってる知らないし
ねただたくさんいるんだよ
とえこれによって神が違うんです
ね地標によって紙が変わるんです
ねこれはウジンという我々何が信行し
たいそこで面白いことは信行したからと
言って得たものは一切何もないん
です例えば中東の国国はすごい豊かで
すごいしっかり国を管理して砂漠でもう
農業やってるんです
野菜やらくだもの優秀してるんです砂漠
でしたけど
元々それであインシャラーとか神かのキブ
嘘ばっかしであの人知識やら科学能力やら
ねいっぱい使ってこの科学者をいろんな国
から雇っ
て高い給料を上げ
て砂漠を緑かにグリーンランドにしちゃっ
たんですそこで水が本当にちょっとしか
ないん
ですそれは精密に計算せ
て水が無駄にならないよう
にで頑張ってるん
ですだ
からなんか行ったことないんだけど上東の
国にま簡単に行けるのルバイとかね行って
みたらびっくりこれさでったかとびっくり
する
ほど変わっていますよこれ信仰じゃないん
ですみんな信仰だから信仰だからていい
加減なこと言うん
です神を信じているんだから
とそうではないん
ですそういうことで各地方に信仰する神が
いてえ例えば西洋の方になるとこのイホて
いう神がいてで
も地方によって変わるんですねマリア様は
信仰したりイエス様は進行したり直接神を
進行したりあるいはセタやらセマイルやら
もうサンタクラースでもいんだ
けどセたちなんだ天使たちを進行した
例えばあの
ロシア何教会というんですからねオークス
クリスティと
いうでは
もうイスではなくてね他のいとをたくさん
いるんです
ね信仰する対象を通し
てえ日本では伝統的に点という言葉使って
ます
ねあれは何なのか誰も分かってないんだ
けどま一応進行はしてきたんですねそこで
この社会が変わっちゃったら今の現代人が
なんかおかしくなってるんですねあの伝統
的な進行システムちょっと今誰もやって
ない壊れてるんですねあ信じてそうすると
なんか探してるんでしょ進行する何かない
のか
とだから極限に詐欺たちが俺は神様で言た
とらてん
です入ってしまって自分の財産なくなって
自分が奴隷なるだけで自分が得たものは何
もないん
ですそうなくても特定の宗教組織に入ら
なくても個人個人でもなんかいりたい気分
でいるんです
ね
それでこの信仰遺伝の場合
は自分が力が
ない痛なる力があって自分を管理して
いるだから偉大なる力の機嫌とって偉大
なる力が決めた決まりを守ると自分
が幸福で無事幸せで生きられるだろうと
いうベクプログラムどんな教にも
です宗教っててものすごいたくさんなり
ます
ね
で世界はそんな状況たくさんないやと勘違
しています私は字はなくて信仰する対象に
よって私は宗教別別に稼げるん
です例えば日本では大仏教て一言葉で違い
ますよ日本では日連教がありまて診断教が
ありまて信教の中でまたベスベ
な宗教ががありましてねでで信仰対象対象
変わると宗教だとインディペンデントレリ
宗教とて私は見るん
ですだから一言葉で全ては仏教っていう風
にまとめることはできませ
ん仏教という宗教だったら信仰対象は何な
のかと分からなくなっちゃうんです
だから仏教という単語あっても仏教と宗教
がないん
ですだから仏教という文化の中でみんな
ちっちゃな小ちゃな小ちゃな宗教たくさん
作っちゃったん
です補欠教信行する人半音信号信行する人
結言教進行する人ゆいを進行する人いい
有重信仰する
人でで信仰対象そうことでたくさんなって
えでまとにかく問題は宗教主になるんじゃ
なくて人間にあるん
です人間が何か信仰したいん
です
そうするとじゃああなたこれ信じたなさと
言っちゃうと信じちゃうん
ですだからこの経済学的に見る
とディマンドか莫大なディマンドがあっ
てそうするとどんなクランサプライでも
売れるん
ですミスが全くないところでどのミスも
売れますよ高いお金
でだから当選な結果とせ宗教組織っていう
のは
かなり豊かで金持ちでえお金が再戦入ると
権力握っちゃって
マスター通して人奴隷にするということを
やっちゃうんです
そうすると信仰の遺伝子が働い人が働い
てる場合は自分が自分の人生設計すかか
ないん
ですあの当てにならない信行システム
が作ったテキスト見てそのに生きようでは
ないかと頑張るん
ですこれを真面目にやってないん
です例えば伝統的な決闘教だったら樹海が
というテキストがあるんですねユダヤ教
だったらペンタテクスといういくつかの本
がありもってえデトロノミていう時あれは
もうテキストです生き
方誰もやってないよあんな風に生きて
みようと思っちゃうと生きていられないん
ですだから宗教はクリスト教ですけど樹海
は守ってないん
ですでもで守ってないんだから
なんか私はいい加減なキリスト教の審議
さんだからま神が
色々きやるでしょうと
ねうまくいかないでしょうとか自己健に
陥ったります
そるだから
[音楽]
このシジね信仰遺伝子が入っちゃうと
自分で人形設計すかかない誰かが作った
テキスト通りに生きようとする例えば正規
末という考えがあって神が再びくると
いう信仰がロッパ型の信仰では必ずあり
ますでアシア方の宗教でもあの正規マスは
考えてはいるんだけどえ神が来て人間
さばいてあれやこれやとか余計なことを
やるとは言ってはないんです
[音楽]
ねだからそれに合わせ
てで頑張ってはいるん
ですそういうわけであの客的
に現実を見てどう生きるかっていうことを
ねあんまり気にし
ないテスで禁にしてるんだ
からということになっちゃうん
ですそこでウシ人の場合は信仰が出てくる
と偉大なるパワーを信じるんであってシが
なく
なるイスミの方まま反対してるんだけど
このテロリストがわれた
でしょで今はまあこでそんなこと書いて
ないやていうことで大体先体的に反対し
てるし今も一部がいるんだけど
ね
だからテロっていうのはあまり理性的じゃ
ないし
ね人に迷惑かけちゃうとねテロリムだから
哲学は平和な社会
に
恐怖与えてやるぞと言ってすごい損害あて
やるぞ
とだからセキリティのためにものすごい大
な金かってるん
です人の自由もなくなってるん
です被告乗るたに我れは
させからあなこちけないんです
ねだかららげにスてのせ現実をめて因果
法則を考えて今やるべきことは今判断する
能力なそれはなくなっちゃうん
です努力するより祈りが大事な大事だと
思うようになり
ますならなきゃだめやと努力はわれません
よというところまで人は大化するんですね
だからこのウシ信仰遺伝子もかなり人間の
人生ダメにしっちゃうんですねはい次に
行き
ます主の問題は感情という心の中ねこれ
スナと書いたんですね
えスナミがきったらお手上げ
ね
感情が割り込むと自己管理は不可能
ですいくら理性があってもこういう風に
行けてみるぞと思ったら感情が割り込ん
じゃうと全部
オフ理性が働きませ
ん結果気にしません感情が悪もと結果どう
でもいいんです感情の発さ
でなんとかやっちゃい
ますそこで全額
は完璧無視するん
です例えば殺す人は船額考えてない
無視そうすると自分の心にたくさん感情
あるでしょう
ねで感情が言うこと真面目にあるん
ですほとんど犯罪になるんです痴漢をし
たり不倫をしたりえねお金ごまかし
たり武将を言っ
たりけた自分の顔写真撮ってねあれ加工
するんです
ね世に存在しない人間のようにでそれは
アプロードするん
です言てあこれ私と思ってるんです
ねだから感情が割り込むと学無視で人は
ロボットになるんただの機械になるん
です結果とせ人間は人間でなくなり
ますだから感情っていうのはまたくさん
ありますから怒怒りと欲と鞭っていうのは
1番大きい感情のでいりのタイプタがなり
ますのタイプがなります
え虫のタイプたくさんあります何でも信じ
るっていうことは虫の感情なんです
ね信じなきゃいないならなきゃだめやとか
ね思っちゃうと虫の感情なんです
ねでエのタイプはまあ大体500種類
ぐらいあって
ね怒りの中ではねま嫉妬やら打ち込みやら
やらね恨みとかね
え色々あります
ね生えるとあんたもロボットです機械
です働くのは感情ですその時船額は考え
ません結果どうでもえん
です動けばいいん
です
はいまそろそろ終わると思いますけど
ねまたトラブルがあるんですで私はこの
ただ人生設計す書く場合は我々の問題どこ
にあるのかと説明してあげてるだけ
ですどこのように書いてくださいと言わ
ないんです
そうすると皆様の自由がなくなっちゃう
でしょだから仏教の仕事はそういうところ
人間絶対気づかない
ところいう
こと希望願望の
新規
結構働いてますね希望願望がくる生きる上
であれて新疲労
です幻覚
ですええと思う
でしょ
何でも希望できる
でしょ皆様何か希望するならばここら辺や
と分かったことは
あるリミットない
でしょだから年取ってあの無限に希望拡大
できなくなるとすごく暗く
若人なんであるかて言うとまあ希望あるわ
あるはあるはある
わだから例えばご飯食べると言ったら1日
何回食べるのがリミットがあるん
ですどれぐらいの量るべきかていう
リミットがあるそれは動物もちゃんと
リミット反義でやってるん
です動物の餌は食べたいと気分があるんだ
けどでもちゃんとリミットがありますです
から餌食べたいていうことは希望願望じゃ
ないん
ですなんか単子はどてみん
ですえリミットがあるんだから
ねで我々にはそのリミットがかかってない
制御がかかってないフリーで働き出す希望
願望という精神的な病気があるん
ですそれを動かし
てそれ起動させて人生設計作れない
でしょう
この希望官房にすいてあのちょっとあの前
のモデュールは全部取りのく取りのく
こちらちょっとやしいんですえ妄想から
起る結論ですは思考ではなく妄想するん
です妄想すると希望願望が現れてくるん
です過去の経験を感情と増せて心の中で
回転させ
ますだから妄想っていうのはこの過去の
ことを感情で回転させるんですでなんか変
なもの作るんです
もする人は今存在し
ない過去に生きて
ます新記に来てるん
ですだって過去はないんだから
ね妄想すると囲にてるん
ですだから今何もやってないん
です世界は先進するものであってえっと
逆進はしないん
です世界ってのはずっと流れるんですこう
これはないんです逆
に後戻りはないん
ですだから人はずっとこの世界のと流れと
一緒にいない
とどうにもならん妄想した途端止まってる
止まって加工に行ってるん
です加工はないん
ですこの
癖みんなにあります
よとても悪い危険なあの軸破壊する
えっと働きなん
ですだ要するに人間には先進できなく
なる進歩できなくなっ
ちゃう進化できなくなっ
ちゃう妄想さえなければ人間っていうのは
すっごいスピードに進化するん
ですお様おし通りにはまあすぐも1週間2
週間
で人格工場完成できますよ
とどれほどいスピーディかという
とでもそやめてもらわないと
ねえ妄想の罠にはまると理性と客観性が
消えますだから進化できないんです
ね生きることは現実的な働きです生き
るっていうことは現実的な働き
です自転車になることと同じに乗って何も
しないで妄想しちゃうと
ね成り立たないでしょうね実際に乗ったら
ずっとこれこなくちゃいかん
ですしょうがないん
です過去生き生きようとする人は生きて
いると言えないん
ですだか格好のことで妄想する人ことは
本当にえ生きてる死人です
よでこれあの坂様ははっきりと死だと
おっしゃってますけどダ端ではあのこの清
一緒ものには裏結構協定があり
ますえ点出しちゃうとすごいあの長くなり
ますので
ねで現代はいい単語あり
ましょ
ゾンビそそ生きてるんですかね死んでるん
ですかねま実際ゾンビはいなんだけど現代
社会ではゾンビという
単語がありますねゾンビの映画もあります
から
ねだから妄想して生きてるならばゾンビ
ですかなりやばいん
ですその人にも人生設計作れないでしょ
だから設計すす書いたけれ
ばゾンビをやめなくちゃいけない現実その
ものを知る見る人にならなくてはいけない
ん
ですはい
大体ポイントはそれで終わるとは思います
けどすに進んでみ
ますうんはい哀れのトラベルポイント大体
これほとんどそんなもんだと思い
ますでできるだけ新しいフレーズで新しい
えっと考えでこのプレゼンテーション
しまったからねえだからまあそろそろ
新しい年になりますから面白いよこういう
プレースで考えちゃう
と妄想する人はゾンビだよ
とだから自分のことを面白く見ればあ今
ゾンビーになっているんだとか
ねえこれ流れが止まるん
ですそれであの言ったあの遺伝
子恐ろしい
ビールスそれは取り除いた方がいいんです
例えば信行遺伝子鳥の足ということはね
相当大変
でょ何も信行しないと恐ろしい人間になる
んじゃないかなと怖かってる
でしょでもすっごい明るい人間になるん
ですえ信仰書してる人々は信仰を持ってる
ん
です真行持ってない人にとってはも面白い
ねとか
ねいぱにやるキャティ見てああすごい建築
ですねとかねあなんですごいですかね綺麗
ですねとかねよ楽しむことできますよ
自分に信仰があると腹が立ちます
ね壊したくなるん
ですだから進行遺伝ビラスがない人は
すごい平和な
人間
でしょはいでは
次にポジティブ
世界どうやって設計す作るのか
と1番大事なポイントは支配者は心ですっ
ていうところです神ではないんです
あるいは信仰遺伝
子自分の心が自分を支配しているん
です命の支配者早々者管理者は自分の心
ですだから信仰いらないよくいるんだから
ね心
が管理者
が早々者
が緒に頼めば自分の心に
アホなことするなよ
と言って簡単
でしょそこで私1番最初にオープンで言っ
た
こと総理大臣に別な心と私に別な心ある
わけじゃないんです誰にもあるのは心なん
です心っていうのは認識機能
別に心と言も何かあるわけじゃないん
です世の中で何も実態とてないんです全て
機能
ですファンクションですものではないん
ですそちょっと難しいんだけどね我々物が
あると思ってるんだからね物はないんです
あるのファンクションです
ファンクションはる
ですあ新しいファンクションになるんです
心もファンクションです心の
ファンクションははっきりしていて認識
機能認識
ファンクションこれみんなにやるんだから
ね
だからネ
も認識してる
でしょだ熱
は低いレベルで私は上のレベルじゃないん
ですそれわかったら全ての生命に心認識
機能あるんだよと分かったらあの人間社会
に限った我々の理解範囲がいめ
れげのめはめ同じ心持ってるんだよ
と同じ心と言ったってもしっかり同じと
いう認識機能を持ってるんだよ
と
だから寝みに聞こえる音は我々には聞こえ
ませ
んネの聴覚世界はすごい違うんですネは
かなり超音波
で超音波を聞いてるんですあの昔あの古い
コンピューター時代
であのビルのネズミたちがコンピューター
機の中に入っちゃってあれ戦後かじったり
色々トラブルが起きたという話があって
なんで来たのことICから音が出るん
です私には昔はICの音を聞こえたんだ
けど今丸切り聞こえませ
んすごい超パ
できっととなんですけどそれがが仕事を
するといろんなことが変わっちゃうん
ですだからICが100200ぐらい
まとめて働くとオンブルなんていう
オーケストみたいなものになっちゃうん
で相当うるさいん
ですで皆様のパソコンはうるさくない
でしょう
ねあのスピーカーで出てくる音以外は
うるさいんです
よでも人間に聞こえないんだけど主に
聞こえるだからねもかじったりするんです
ねああこしは可愛いと思噛んでみよう
とだからネにも聴覚世界あるん
ですこれ同意すってわけじゃないんです私
に聞こえるものネに聞こえるネに聞こえる
もの私に聞こえるではないん
です昨日として覚機能がある年機能が
あるだから心は支配者っていうとことを
理解するとその時点で全て宗教が終わり
です信仰の問題は消え
ますそ心の闇病気については心配すること
になるだから奴隷遺伝子えっとマ主人遺伝
子
マスジスレーブジンそういうのはなんか心
にトバルがあるんだとあこれ直そうって
いうことになってくるん
です
はいこれれで心の特色
は谷にアできないん
です全く自分の心自分の心
でで私の手足などなどは他人にも触ったり
いじったり殴ったりすることできますよ心
にエクセスできないん
です
しかし世界勘違してますよ他人の影響を
受ける他人に言われてこうなったんだ
と父親が厳しかったんだから私は自信の
ない人間になりまったとかね
母親が厳しかったんだ
から私はこんな人間になっちゃったとか
いつでも他人のを整理するでしょみんな
ああああなるほどなるほどじゃあこれどう
すればいいかと会計す策まで考えちゃうん
です全てアウト
です母親に子供の心にアセできません
人の心にアセできるとはいますよそれは心
ものすごく成長させ
て心ものすごく綺麗にして心の波長をよく
理解し
ている人々にはこの認識する時はこの波長
が起こるん
です心の波長がちょっと物質波長にあの
入っちゃうん
ですでそれがチェックできるようにはなり
ますけど一般人にはこれできるわけじゃ
ないん
です
そこで私たち
は心の扉開けてるん
ですだから人
の言葉生っちゃうと心は振動するしえっと
の顔の顔を見ると心が振動するし
自分がそうさせているん
です分かり言えばあの洗脳っていう現実
あります洗脳された後でも洗脳されたいと
が
洗脳なんて言います
か自分が送るオパにしたじゃあどうぞ洗脳
してくださいと許可したん
です
アクセス剣上げたん
ですここは決断する私はこの別なところで
共演する時はこういう例行ったん
です例えば人がピストルを持ってきて
ちゃんと玉入っ
てるいきなりそれだってもう顔もすごい怖
そうな顔で
乱暴な人でピストルを頭にけて立ちなさい
よ
と立たなかったら一発やるぞと脳みそ
に言うと相手が当選足す
でしょはい手あげなさいと
当選てあげる
でしょうその場合はこの人立たしたのは
この反射者ですかねピストルを持って
いる手あげなさて手あげさせたのはこの
ピストル持ってる人ですか
ね日本では皆様のイメージ難しいかも
アメリカだと思ってください
アメリカで人のポケの中でチョコレート
あるよりも目玉があるよりもピストルが
あることは確かですから
ねこれの弾入れて
ますそうすると我々はこの犯人がこの望な
人が脅して自分を立たせ
た自分を殺すと脅して手を上げさせたと
思うんだけど違い
ます自分の心が怯え
て自分の心が司令するんです立て立て立て
立てなかったらまい
と心が震えてるんです震えて怯えて心が
自分に司令するの立ちなさいとですから
あのピストルじゃないん
ですよく考えてくださいピストルもて立ち
なさいよ別に立ちませんよ私は座ってます
と言えない言え
ます所に私は座ってただから
ねいえましょその結果打たれて死ぬかも
しれませんだけどでも立たないでいること
はでき
ます財布出しなさい
と言ったらこの人は怖いんだからその人
の司令で財布が出ててはないんで自分があ
財布出した方が身の安全やと思って自分の
心で手を伸ばして財布出すんですえ出し
まし私も本読んでるんだから
ね行っちゃったら
どう言えます
よ大体それぐらい落ちしかる人は世界は
脅ししませ
ん逆にその人怖くなるん
ですすっごく落ち着いてる私は実験した
こともあり
ますみんな怖いやべえ言ったら言ってどう
元気ハワイと言ったら向
ちゃだからこれ心の問題なん
でしょうだから財布ま今本読んでるんだ
からそんな暇がないんですて言ったらその
自分がぶん殴ってえねポケットも破って
もう財布持っていくか
もそれは別な話
でそういうわけで全て心が主人だから心の
知で生けてるん
ですコマーシャル見て
ねコマーシャルにやられちゃって品物を
買ったではないんですアホのアホはあなた
ですなんで乗ったんですかと
あいい品ものだあこれ安そうとかねそれだ
から私はこのあの大体あのというえテレビ
なんとかチャンネルありますねあの品物
売っ
てる全く安くないん
ですでも安以上に作家を起こすために喋る
わ喋るわ喋るわ喋る
わこの掃除を買う場合はなんて今だけやと
ボールペンもすいてましょう
と無料
で乗るん
です
乗るからあののお金かかってねテレビ
チャネルで1時間ぐらいくらんしな
もの売れるんですか
ねすごい金かかるでしょうね1本ごと
にまあ正直にボールペンすいてないかも
しれませんだけどおかしくするためにそ
例え出したんだけどあの正直のイスタンド
も無料でくれるとかねそれに合わせ
スタンドは
他どうしますか
ねあるいは
あの
あの反動の掃除も1つすいてきましょうと
これは別に買うとあの6000円ですけど
セットでなんて2000円です
とえてちゃうとよく見るとネットで買え
ますねもっと安くてもっと一しな
ものアソンでムソ宣伝してるわけじゃない
んだ
けど
だから
この特にあのアメリカのああいうこああ
いうマーケティングチャルっていうのは
最低も
バレバレ人を騙しととするやらやりくり
はあれに乗る人いることもう不思議で
しょうがないん
です
日本のチャネルよりはかなり激しくやっ
ちゃい
ます激しくやればやるほどもうすっぺて
ネタバレてるんです
ねだからみんな人間てえのもう何でも餌
だっちゃえば食っちゃう連中やと思ってる
ん
ですいまいたら食いましょう
とみんなま結局はそういうこと
でしょその人の人生設計何考えてるんです
か
ねまいったらすぐ食っちゃいますから
ねだからこの心主人ということは理解して
ください自分をりして
ください
コマーシャル見てはあ感動し自分のせい
でしょう
ね自分が感動したでしょうねあ自分が
うるさいなこれはとか思っちゃえば本当に
うるさいん
でしょだから10万へのしなものはね
99万9999
そういうわけで他人に決断させることは
できません他人が決断してください今1分
以ないでとかねこの番組放送してる間で
注文してくださいと言うん
です
それでさらに決断させるために注文さとし
てますよとLINEも行くん
です時々数字くん
です
436人とか
ねそれでちょっと見るとえ
617人じゃあ私がうろしていると全部
売れ切れちゃいますよ
とて大数決まってるんだよとそんなこと
言うんだ
から全てそうです大数決まってるわけじゃ
ない月の日電話したって
もお金払っちゃばも残るん
ですで主のテレビ向て同じ番組のリピート
言ってるんだからね意味がないでしょ
で私はあのたまにダイエットのために見る
んですあの外色々仕事に行きますからまあ
あれ見るともう食欲のところかもいめ
たってもいられない超悪い気ぶりになるん
ですあ大やってないんです食欲なくなり
ます
うんえとそういう冗談がいったの
は今決断してきて今決めてください頼ん
でるでしょうねやっぱり決めるのは自分の
心決断するのは自分の
心私は皆様パメスやってください言えます
けどじゃやりまと皆様決めなきゃどうにも
ならこでみんな瞑想はするそと私は第1
条件妄想完全突してくださいとそうすると
あっという間に成功しますよ
とあというところはま15年も経ってるん
です
ね何やってみんな妄想してるんで瞑想では
なくだから妄想やめてくださいやっぱり
決断しない妄想やめます
とだから地開するために1番
大きな壁が障害がそうですこれがそ進め
しまったからねこれはやりたいでしょやめ
ないやめないんです
ねだから結果がなくなっちゃうんですね
そう言ったからと言って書人が決断しない
とね成り立て
ない
うんしかし無の闇にわている心は物質の奴
になって果てられてるんです心にもう1つ
問題あります心には無というもうこの条件
があるんです
ねただいるだけで認識するんであるするん
だ
けどなんかちょっとハデが入ってるん
ですだから心が自分が主人じゃないと思っ
てるん
です思ってこの
物物とものではない波長
です物質の波長で自分がやられているんだ
と
例えば今なんか音楽でも流れたら皆様が私
の声じゃなくてああいい気分だ聞いちゃう
でしょああ気持ちいいやとかねということ
は音は物質
でしょあ心が物質の波長にやられた
と違てやられたんじゃないん
です心がアホで妙で持
で自分が主人やと知らない
だけだから音楽流れて
も期間と決めたら聞こえない
よ期間こんなのはと聞こえ
ます
この花はどのように見えるのかということ
は皆様の心を決めるん
です鼻が綺麗だから気持ちよかったわけ
じゃないん
ですこれ無な心が
ああの方がとても美しいでしたから心の
愛情が感情が湧いてきまったよと他人のせ
に
そる弱
ですで心の大きな問題れなんでだから我々
は物質を神様にしているん
です物質の奴隷になってるん
です人間の心が救った物質でしょ今生き
てる社世界
は人間が救った世界でしょこ建物であろう
か照明であろうか音声であろうか椅子で
あろう
か人間救ってそれからホールの奴隷に
なる音声の奴隷に
なる面白い
でしょう
自分ですっ
てだからあの色々あの神様は人間作る
でしょ見たいとは誰もいませんだけど観音
玉とかね歩産とかね店で売ってますからね
大体8000円9000円程度
で売り買ってきて裁断速でてはあ
ありがとうもてくださいと何やってるかと
さっぱりわから
ない自分ですったの
に自分で買った品物
でしょそれからどうやって自分を支配
するだからこれ宗教と関係なく世界そう
なっている我々は今
の機械文明にやられてるんです機械に
合わせてるんですね人生は時計に合わせて
いるん
です私たちは何時に起きるか何時に寝るか
何時にご飯食べるかが全て自分が救った
世界自分の心が救った世界それが逆
にこれ何か例え話言った方がま分かり
やすいん
です自分の楽しみに犬を
買う買ってから犬言通りにやる生ってみる
あワンチシャポしたっ
では散歩に行こうとかあわんちゃんがお腹
が空いてるでは餌あげようとあわんちゃん
が可愛がってほしいとなんか寂しがってる
では変ってあげるそうことか
ね大体犬飼ってるみんな犬の奴隷
でしょ犬に買われてる
でしょそれすごい分かりやすい霊なん
です
犬買っても猫買ったっても他の動物買っ
たってもえすぐ自分の心に愛情が生まれた
とかた向こうは自分を支配
するだからこれ心の大きな
問題自分が救ったものだ
からなんで自分が救ったものに逆に支配さ
れるんですか
ねあまりにもおかしい
でしょそれには鞭無というんです
ねだから誰の心物質神様やと思って物質の
奴隷になって物質のためにただの波長
でしょそのためにけてることになっちゃう
ん
です心自律させると自由にさせることを各
個人の人生設計にするべき
ですそういうこと
で人生設計っていうの
はワンポイントで説明できます心自律させ
てください心が主人です
逮捕するなよ
と足かせてかするなよと透けるなよ
と他人に私の心直すことを
もことも自由にさせることもできませ
んあんたは自由でたんとは言ったからで
言って
ね意味が
ない
はいそこ
で心独立させるために必要な地位があり
ますこれ因果法則なん
です因果法則を理解するべきです因果法則
っていうのはもう人間に理解できないほど
できない
ぐらいすっごい世界なん
です今まで人間っていうのはこの物質が
あると思っていたんだからあのかだから
それより物質がない場合は波長だけの世界
だからねそれだけの世界だから
ねそう簡単じゃないんですでも我々に必勝
な範囲があります
ね行為に必ず結果が
ある簡単
でしょアクション
リアクション物の世界でもそれを送る
です心の世界でも心が何かやったら結果も
出てくる心はやることは精々認識すること
だけ
です他で何もできん何か認識したら好結果
が出て
くる例えば何か見て美味しいご飯だと認識
する
主食いたいて欲が生まれるん
です仕方がないん
です美味しいご飯だと認識して
たらだからいい気持ち悪いとは出てこない
ねだから気持ち悪くなったと出てこ
ない決まってる
です博物感ででもあるいはどこかの
えっと美術感でもえ何かすごい高華な
エクセリを
見るちょっと馬鹿でかいダイヤを
見るあこれ珍しいダイヤですねまるまる
さんがすかったいたいやだよとか
ねで認識したらそれなりの反応が起こり
ますということで認識したら主義の結果が
出ている
これで結果は今私の生き方が今までの私の
認識過程の結果
です今体調が悪いんだったらあなたの心の
問題だよ
とあたに食欲がなくなっているまそれは
あなたの認識の結果ですと
ちょっと体もに悪いのにあんた食欲大勢だ
から認識の問題です
と全て認識の問題
ですだから今の自分とはちょっと前やった
行為の結果です結果どうしようもないん
ですだから我々は恋する時気をつけるん
です石を投げたらもうどうにもならん
ですそちらに窓ガラスあったらこれ
割れるで石を投げる時気をつければ石も
投げたいんだけど悪い結果がが出して
欲しくないんだったらちょっと角度変えて
投げるど窓ガラスにはた当たらないとその
結果に
なるだから人生設計っていうのは行をする
時結果考えなさい
とでこいう
の主は心ですこいうは心がってますこの
その時石という専門力があるんです心に石
が起こるん
です石がどんどん書いて例えばもうこう
いうに石があってなんか気分が悪いとかね
それで結果通ってなんかやりたいなとかね
それで手に体に信号がいて石もあって石も
取って向こうはすごい高華な窓ガラスも
見えちゃって
なんか色々してるんだからねだけ
ちゃうでまら
割れるでそういう結果になりますねだから
で心の中であの感情から意思というものを
生まれるんです
よ意でこいうをするん
です
そこで世界が変るっていうのはそれで世界
変わって変わっていくん
です心によって世界が変わっていくん
ですだったら良い結果になるようにすれば
簡単
でしょでそれに合わせて心に関係ある物質
世界も変わり
ます私たちにこちらにいてあの好のは
いじることはできませんです
けどま我々の心にはあるできる範囲で物質
を管理することができ
ますうんえ行為に船額はありません
がこに船額がありませんが意によって船額
が成り立ち
ますだ私はこのカップを
壊すカップが壊れることは線でも悪でも
ないん
です必勝なエネルギーが入るとカップが
壊れるん
です線でも悪でもないんですしかし
あの必なエネルギーが私が与えてならば
どう
なる私の心にこのカップ腹が立って
イライラし
て1てたまっ
てカップ
をぶん殴りたいと思っちゃったん
ですそこでカップ殴ったところでカップが
割れてしまい
ますそれは悪行為
ですカップが割れたことは為じゃないん
ですそれは姿勢が遅
ですだから世の中で善悪はないん
です心にあるんです心の意にあるんです
結もちゃ
た平らかな心で生きることはしって決定的
な法則になるますだからもう決定的ですよ
人間が清らかな心で生きるべき
です清らかな心で行為するもの全部全行為
になるんです
例えばカップを割ること
も悪コイルになる場合もあるし全行なるい
まり
ます分かりません
よで心でしょだ
からきらな心出るしかないんですはい次に
行き
ますそれから人形設計図考える時のまた
やっちゃいますねこれも世間の見
方これはこの生き方にそれほど関係あり
ません
よ世間の生き方別に関係ないです自分が来
てるんだからねで私気になるんですよ職業
服装認められる評価されることなどは人生
設計のガイドラインにならないん
ですみんな自分どう生きるべきかと思っ
たら世間の見方チェックするんですどうで
もいいんですそんなのの
は自分の心きらにするだけなん
ですだから世間の評価は参考にならないん
です世間が神様でもないしブッダでもない
し
ねだから
気をつけてください世間に褒められるよう
に生きるとは自分自身がロボットになる
ことですみんなに褒められるように生きて
みようて言ったらあんたはロボットです
だってみんないい加減でしょ褒めたり褒め
なかったりけっ
たり
または世間を騙す生き方をすることです
あるいは世間を
騙す騙しちゃうと騙された世界が自分を
褒めるでも長持ちはしません
よ他人に自分の一面を見えても洗面的に
見えませんだから自分のことは世間は知ら
ないん
です皆様に私のことは1面しか見えないん
です
よだからあなたのこと世間がギャギャ
ギャギャ何言ってもみんなに一面しか見え
てないんですだからあんまり世間の見方て
いうのは人生設計では参考にしないん
です自分を生化する人はかなり無理をして
います時々我々自分を正当化するんでしょ
こういうわけでこういうわけでこうその人
無理をしてるん
ですなぜ無理してるか自分がやったことは
世間に批判されて欲しく
ない
別に生徒化しなく自分の意思でやっちゃっ
たんだ
から
はいこれ世間のことについてあのまあ何が
ブッダの言葉も入れなきゃだめでこれ役は
調べてないんです
あの
ま点結構ありますけどねこれダ
の芸ですね
34番で
金定で
金定坂様がある行者に合うんです
この行者見る
とすごいでょ見た目
が服着てないん
ですこの代わりに
あの鹿の
かなんとかして体に透けてやるん
ですそれからかみのけ
あみのけ部あまのべでんでじです
けどなんか結んでおいてあるんです
ねそういうことでいろんな宗教道具を持っ
て首にお住所をえ抱え
てあれやこれや道具を持って髪の毛もある
特定の姿に髪の毛をして普通の服きないで
なんか鹿の川
ででかこけてるんで修行社と
てお様から見ればこの人
は修行者の服装で業者を演じているんです
ね業者演じているなせ人は行者を演じるの
かというと世間からこの人は生食者修業者
業者宗教家という風に認めて欲しいん
です世界の宗教は一緒だってそんなこと
やってますよ
いろんな服装があって飾り物があって太鼓
があって長い術があってそちらに輪があっ
てこれこドンドンとと音が出たりとか
ね歩き方も決まっ
て一般人を感動させたい
でしょ世間の世間に評価して欲しいん
ですバカバカらしいんで世間が悟ってない
でしょう
ね世間が心の状況知りてるわけじゃない
でしょうね世間様が死んで知ってるわけ
じゃないでしょうね世間様にはもう加速の
面なでもう人生終わってるん
です
だから世間に褒めてもらいともらいたく
やることがイチ詐欺犠牲ということをね
お釈迦様言わないで言うん
ですおさん厳しい言葉使わないん
ですでおさtheme
ofそれ
だけ
この何の
意味ばんたらんせがなんあなたの心の中
はちゃめちゃ汚れてるんだよ
となのにあんた外を磨いて外にいろんな
ペンキ塗ってるんだよ
とバラパマそれのゲのみなんでですだから
このおささにあった行者だけじゃなくて
世界にあるどんな宗教の世界でも衣装衣装
意匠で儀式儀式儀式で一般人を感動さ
せようと時々ね鬼の青鬼赤鬼の顔もかぶっ
てあそれなりに変なものを腰まいてやっ
てるでしょ
うん
で鬼外服は打ていっちゃうとそうなると
思ってるん
です修行者が服装儀式ギレなどに執着せて
断ってきていてもそれが外の飾れ
です修業世界いつでもそうなるんですよ手
の込み
方座り
方1回あのこれあんまり言ってはいかんか
なアルフさん
の
えっと道場の中になんとか入ったんです私
が私と一緒に偉いお坊さんがいたんだけど
このまどよなの作り方こういう風にあの
瞑想させできるようにましっかりできて
ましょう
とただこのらのえ中に入ってんでこれ中に
入ってはいけませんも人々は座って寝てる
場所に入ったってもんねベスにせと言っ
たってもそれ寝てるだけで
ね何言うんですか
ねまそれは言ってないんだ
けどやっぱり式
たり座千道に入るならばそれなるの儀式
切れ色々やって身を極めて資格取らないと
入ったはいかんや
とさ昨日下に座れて言ってるんだけどねに
電車の中で佐に座って瞑想したってで1人
迷惑ない限り
はだからまこれは自分たちの宗教の世界で
もそうやって儀式式だりあってやってどう
歩くのかどんな風に転聞くのか手を結ぶ
ならば左が外か右が外
か歩く場合はに右足か左足かとかね言うわ
言うわ言うわあまりうるさいんだから私も
お寺とは仲良くすることやめちゃった
と私左まらなくじゃがんでしょしめど
くさくて覚えられないん
で別に失礼ではないんだ私の気持ち
は簡単単純だったらやりますけど
えとにかく
まあ仏教の周波によって式だり習慣が
変わりますよおじすの変わって形も変わり
ますから
ねどんな信仰かっていうことによって私は
知らないおじは何のためにあるんですか
とある日本で超有名な方がそれもらの方
ですけど自分が一でもおじ持ってるんだよ
とま教授もやっていたんだけどねあなた
おじ持ってるんだ私に聞いたんですだ私お
も持すのはね先しの帽子やと何の言っ
ちゃったん
ですその時若かったし
ね詐欺し
でしょあの人の顔があの難しい黒い色に
なっちゃったん
です行ってからまいこと言っちゃったなと
もう終わっちゃったんだから
だから自分がいつでも落ち着きましょとね
おじ触るとねちゃんとあれこれどうそう
どうそうとま言いましたけどねだからおじ
持すか持たないかで本物のボスかエチボス
かて決めるならば
ねかわいそう
ねでだからあのま仏教の場合はそれほど
ひどくないんだけど他の宗教の世界では
ね他の進行組織ではねまアフリカから
インドネシアもうどんな国でもあります
からね服装はねどんな仮かぶるのかどんな
葉っぱ腰の周りにけるのかどうか
ねどんな鳥の羽が頭に刺すのかどか
ねとにかく人々はそうやって
この外なんかかさったら
は
大きやと思ってます
よじゃあ今このこちらで大体の外国では
この喋ってる人の名前とか書くでしょもし
こうこういう風な冗談考えましょうこちら
でスサーでプレジデントofUnited
stesかい
たら我
あらないんでしょう
ねだから人形人生設計すっていうのは心
計らにする
ことその心は男でも女でもないん
です心は年より若いて問題ないんです
心っていうのはある波
ですこれをらにせて
さ感て
さ
はいはいそれでプログラム的に言えばこの
ポジティブ
エネルギー今ネガティブの世界大体いった
とポジティブエルギでくださいとあの感情
で行う行為
は悪い行為でネガティブ結果を出し
ます感情あの
新規感情が生えた途端みんなやっちゃい
ます
よだめやめなさいで言ったってもやめて
くれませんそれぐらい感の神は強いんです
しかしそれはネガティブエネルギーで悪い
結果出し
ますどんな生き方をしても豚人地の感情で
汚れた行為をしないように努力するだから
我々はもうどんな仕事をしてもいいんです
どんな生き方してもいいん
です一緒でも豚人地だけ使いませんよ
と
人どなってもいいんですでも怒りは使い
ませんよ
と欲はすいませんよて虫は使えませんよ
となぜならば豚人地っていうのは感情です
感情の3人の様
です7つわったら七輪侍とも言いますけど
けどミスしかないん
ですだから三振になるんですいなしに
ある豚人地が入ると悪行為
ですネガティブ
です全脳感情で生きてもるだ
からこれは
設計スだからねはいこれ難しいよ今日から
よく怒り無との理性がないというこれでは
生きてません
と決めるそれで心気だからなるそれだけ
でしょ人生設計っていうの
は幸福を期待しなくても幸福になるみよく
したことをするみんな幸福を期待
する神様にお祈りすればもう大恵みに恵ま
られる
とま石が来て頭に落ちるかもしれませんだ
けどもないん
です幸福期待する必ないん
です幸福になりたいなな思ってるでしょ
その人同時にはどんな裏でどんな働きやっ
てますか我は不幸だ我は不幸だと自分に
自己じかけてるん
です幸福になりたいなあすごい危険です
よ我は不幸だという確定がなければあの
妄想希望が生まれません
よとても機嫌なことなんです
これはあの他人がね幸福で頑張って
くださいということと違うん
です他人があんたしっかり幸せになり
なさい言うと大体なんとなくじゃあ頑張り
ますって気持ちはなり
ます
そこでネガティブ豚人をやらないで生きて
みると幸福になってるんですだって船員は
全が作るんだから
ねベースに祈らなくても幸福になり
ますえ自者は理解しやすいポジティブ
エネルギーですそれであのポジティブ
エネルギーはリストあります今日書き
ながら考えたんだけど全てポレのリストも
紹介しようかなとかね考えた瞬間であこれ
無理もうタグはないえと日本語の単語ない
ということでま無理ですねあれは
ポジティブのリストはあるん
ですでも誰もそれはしっかりとりしてない
んだからまあまあちょっとスタディーして
研究してリストを現代人に分かるよう
に直さなくちゃいけないんですえ
ポジティブリストありますがまおさ様は
簡単に自者で生きてみなさいよ
と全ての生命に対してそれで話終わりと
簡単や
と全ての生命にけしに全ての生命の幸せの
ため願っ
てけてみれ
ば抜抜群なポジティブエネルギー心に入っ
てきますその痛は
もう確実にいやいやといったっても幸福に
なるん
です因果関係を考えてするならばポジに
なる
あるいはこれやるとどんな結果になるか
なあてちょっとチェックすれ
ばアス怒鳴りたいんだ
けどどなったらどうなるのかとちょっと
チェックする相性殴りたいんだけど殴っ
たらどうなるとちょっと結果考えれば理性
というん
[音楽]
ですそれポジになります理性とは因果関係
を種に参考することです私はずっと
うるさいほど言うで理性が大事やと理性
っていうのは因果関係考えることですね
例えばカップを取る場合はどんな風に取れ
ばよかとそれ
だけ心配ですね
うんまたくさなるような気がしますねまだ
あの心の病気あの習得執着依存というあの
これは心の問題でまさーっと呼んで終わり
にしますあの奴隷という勘違いで生きてる
ので心はえ極端に弱いんです心が主人
でしょうねどれじゃないん
ですこれ心自分がどれやと思ってるんです
だから1人1人の心がもう極端に弱いん
です心にはすっごいエネルギーがあるん
です何でも作られるエネルギーがあるん
ですでもどれだったらどれやと思ってる
ならばどうしようもない
でしょう物質に他の生命に感情に思考妄想
に執着してるんですだから私の心が物質に
執着している他の生き物に執着している
自分自身の感情にやられて
いる自分自身の思考妄想にやられていてわ
心
が自由にならないだから心に自由に活動
でき
ない戦地洗脳の心です
けど閉じられてるん
ですスは無常で変化するのだと常に
思い出して現象に対する執着を徐々に
減らすように生きてみますこれで設計す格
人がそう思い
ます
まあ執着あるんだけどやっぱり無償だから
まあ消える
でしょうという感じ
で例えば自分の体力に執着あるまあでも
おいるからねそなくなるでしょうと自分の
健康にえい自慢するえ自慢したってもね
細胞だから
ね健康がなくなるかわからんていう感じで
執着を
減らす服を買ってすごいもう来たら古く
なりますから
ねそういう風に
この減らせます
よ執着があってもなくてもご飯を食べられ
ます服を切られますここで言いたいの
はみんな執着なくなるとええ大変思ってる
でしょ大丈夫です執着ない方が白人
ですだってなくなったっても減っちゃるだ
から
ね
例えば具体的なレバねお腹が空いたら執着
あろうかなかろうかご飯食べられる
でしょう執着あってもなくても服は切られ
ます
でしょ執着あってもなくてもすかれたら寝
られる
でしょ執着があってもなくて
も寝てそれから目覚めるでしょ別にいら
ない
よ着
は執着っての余計な迷惑です例えばなんか
長高で電車に
乗る特急に結構かっこよくできてるあ
なんて綺麗ですかなんて美しいですかとか
ね結構かっこいい電車あります
よこれで着ると降りる場合は何のおしゃれ
もない駅でしょうだから長距離電車で田舎
の駅で降りるでしょ東京の駅と違います
から
ねなんかちょっと心が
ねだから別に執着があってもなくても電車
に
乗れる電車はすごくかよくできてるならば
執着があってもなくても気分よくい
られる問題ないん
ですはいそういうことで執着は余計な迷惑
です徐々に減らした方がよろしいと思い
ますはい次にいき
ますはいこれでターゲットリストで終了し
ます遺症で病んでる心を直す
生方心はます層でこれ直す生き方弱い心を
主する生き方汚れた心を清らかにする生き
方え奴隷だと勘違いしてる心に心こそが
主人であるときづかせる生き
方自律自由安穏を目指す生き
方幻想のを破って心理を発見する生き方
このターゲットで設計スを作るんですはい
終わりでしょうかね終わりですうんはい
それで今日の講演は勝利でござい
ます何時ちょ時間ですちょうど時間
です
ん
あでは休憩なしスパでそれであの祈願問で
祈願で終了します一緒に取れ
ましょう
[音楽]
[拍手]
UR生命が悲しむなく一切の生命が
あんのんでありますように
ササはい中屋時間どうもありがとうござい
[拍手]
ます